[Música]
y
el presidente de los eeuu donald trump y
el candidato por el partido demócrata la
presidencia joe biden se enfrentan esta
noche en el gran primer esperado debate
presidencial serán seis segmentos de 15
minutos cada uno en donde no veremos la
tradicional estrechez de mano de los dos
candidatos debido a la panda n será
precisamente este el tema central de
discusión en las plataformas que tienen
los dos candidatos para hacer frente a
la crisis económica y salud de
coronavirus pero también habrán temas
polémicos que se abordarán como por
ejemplo la declaración de impuestos del
presidente de donald trump así como las
marchas por justicia racial en todo el
país y la presión para elegir a un
miembro de la corte suprema y que sea
aprobado por el senado
los dos candidatos llegan a este debate
con una diferencia de seis puntos a
nivel nacional a favor de joe biden y
con una gran ventaja también dentro de
los votantes latinos
[Música]
y aquí en florida votantes hispanos
demócratas y republicanos estarán muy
pendientes del primer debate parte de la
política exterior hacia américa latina'
de la administración trump se ha
enfocado en la crisis en venezuela y en
a acabar según dice con los regímenes de
cuba y nicaragua un discurso que ha
utilizado también durante la campaña
advirtiendo que bailén está respaldado
por la izquierda más radical de la
región un mensaje que está calando
especialmente entre los votantes cubanos
y venezolanos de mayor edad que no
quieren un presidente como bailén al que
consideran un socialista que podría
convertir eeuu en un país comunista es
por eso que no sería sorprendente que
donald trump volviera a usar ese mensaje
durante el primer debate presidencial a
pesar de que bardem y el partido
demócrata insisten en que sus planes
socialistas se limitan a una reforma
migratoria y un plan médico que
beneficie a toda la población aunque
quizás el tema hispano queda reservado
para el segundo debate que tendrá lugar
aquí en la ciudad de miami
[Música]
aquí en california hay una gran
expectativa por lo que va a hacer el
vivero debate presidencial entre donald
trump y joe biden en california como en
arizona los dos campañas los dos
candidatos han intensificado su
acercamiento con las minorías
afroamericanos e hispanos especialmente
pero han hecho un micro targeting de la
comunidad hispana enfocándose mucho más
por ejemplo en la campaña republicana en
los pequeños empresarios mientras que la
campaña demócrata se ha enfocado mucho
más en los hispanos jóvenes buscando el
voto de esta comunidad que tiene gran
número de habitantes aquí en california
y en arizona y que de salir a votar
podría marcar una gran pauta en lo que
va a hacer esta elección presidencial
del 3 de noviembre
[Música]